Jake:这一个
Jake: This one.
Jake:一个插头是吧
Jake: One plug, right?
Shure: 是的然后咱们弄几个锅
Shure: Yeah, and then we'll get a few pots.
Shure: 是弄一个锅还是两个锅
Shure: Should we use one pot or two?
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake
Shure: 一个锅
Shure: One pot
Jake:有两个锅是吗
Jake: We have two pots, right?
Shure: 对有两锅
Shure: Yeah, we have two pots.
Jake:这个不用垫
Jake: This one doesn’t need a mat.
Lucia: 他们居然真的有鸳鸯锅这个东西
Lucia: They actually have this divided pot thing.
Shure: 那就用一个这个吧先
Shure: Let’s just use this one for now.
Jake:用两个锅
Jake: Use two pots.
Shure: 用两个锅
Shure: Use two pots.
Jake:一个不用电
Jake: One doesn’t need electricity.
Jake:就一个用电
Jake: Just one needs electricity.
Shure: 底下还有一个不用电的
Shure: There’s another one that doesn’t need electricity underneath.
Jake:咱没那么多菜
Jake: We don’t have that many ingredients.
Shure: 这气好像不是那么多问题
Shure: The gas doesn’t seem to be that much of a problem.
Shure: 应该也不大
Shure: Shouldn’t be a big deal.
Jake:这个是
Jake: This one is.
Lucia: 冰箱的电源吗
Lucia: Is this the fridge power?
Jake:可以用对
Jake: Yes, you can use it.
Jake:但是插墙上就行
Jake: But just plug it into the wall.
Shure: 我操这个
Shure: Damn this
Jake:看一看还有看还有多少
Jake: Check and see how much is left
Alice:这个叉子
Alice: This fork
Shure: 这个插座上面
Shure: On this outlet
Lucia: 插排插插排插排插插排
Lucia: Power strip, power strip, power strip
Shure: 对这个插座上面
Shure: Yes, on this outlet
Shure: 插排插插排
Shure: Power strip, power strip
Shure: 插插排插插排
Lucia: 会不会有安全隐患
Lucia: Will there be any safety hazards?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no
Lucia: 不会不会
Lucia: No, no
Shure: 死不了放心真的
Shure: You won't die, don't worry
Jake:这个大家都是这么火的
Jake: This is how everyone does it
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Shure: 都已经如此生活30年了
Shure: We've been living like this for 30 years
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 没事这个不会的啦这个没问题的
Lucia: Don't worry, it won't be a problem
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem
Jake:外边都是这么搞
Jake: This is how it's done outside
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:并且我们这个是民牌插足
Jake: Plus, this is a reputable brand
Alice:公牛是吗
Alice: Bull, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Alice:好看到公牛我放心了
Alice: Seeing Bull makes me feel relieved
Shure: 然后就是坐这的同学稍微注意一些
Shure: Then the people sitting here should be a bit more careful
Tasha: 哈哈由我来进行一个开箱仪式吗
Tasha: Haha, should I do an unboxing ceremony?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Alright, alright
Lucia: 开箱的工作交给你了
Lucia: The unboxing is up to you
Shure: 这白菜洗没洗呢
Shure: Has this cabbage been washed?
Lucia: 我负责取快递你负责开箱
Lucia: I'll handle the delivery, you do the unboxing
Alice:还没呢
Alice: Not yet
Shure: 那要不洗洗一下子
Shure: How about washing it quickly then?
Alice:确实得洗
Alice: It definitely needs washing
Alice:金针菇啥的也得洗一下
Alice: The enoki mushrooms need washing too
Alice:这种也得过一下
Alice: This kind also needs a rinse
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: Aha
Alice:没洗手
Alice: Didn't wash hands.
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thank you.
Shure: 虽然没洗手
Shure: Even though I didn't wash my hands.
Shure: 但是不干不净
Shure: But a little dirt doesn't hurt.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick.
Jake:我怎么知道我订单尾号是什么
Jake: How do I know what the last digits of my order are?
Tasha: 感觉像诈骗
Tasha: Feels like a scam.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:不是不是订单尾号快递
Jake: No, no, it's the last digits of the delivery.
Tasha: 什么时候吃晚饭
Tasha: When are we having dinner?
Lucia: 快
Lucia: Soon.
Shure: 打算在群里喊一下
Shure: Planning to announce it in the group.
Shure: 回家吃饭了
Shure: Time to go home for dinner.
Lucia: 在群里吗
Lucia: In the group?
Shure: 对在群里
Shure: Yes, in the group.
Jake:没吧没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Alice:可以再来一个吗
Alice: Can I have another one?
Tasha: 是啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 没事不是每个人都要吃到一个
Tasha: It's okay, not everyone needs to get one.
Lucia: 那我再来一个吧
Lucia: Then I'll have another one.
Tasha: 啊这个能至于
Tasha: Ah, does it really matter?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:我也觉得
Alice: I think so too.
Alice:因为他没有被压
Alice: Because it wasn't pressed down.
Shure: 啊稍微稍微冲一下
Shure: Ah, just rinse it a bit.
Shure: 虽然这应该是干净的
Shure: Although it should be clean.
Tasha: 其实我想问这个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to ask this.
Alice:嗯你说什么
Alice: Hmm, what did you say?
Tasha: 那个瓦斯罐应该装在哪
Tasha: Where should the gas canister be placed?
Shure: 刚才好像装进去了
Shure: I think it was just placed in.
Tasha: 装进去了
Tasha: It was placed in.
Tasha: 嗯行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 我宿舍就有
Shure: I have one in my dorm.
Shure: 一个非非常不安全
Shure: It's very, very unsafe.
Alice:真牛逼
Alice: Really impressive.
Tasha: 我没有
Tasha: I don't have one.
Shure: 大家不要学
Shure: Don't learn from me, guys.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 也可以烧水的哦
Shure: You can also use it to boil water.
Shure: 电水热水壶
Shure: Electric kettle
Tasha: 月饼
Tasha: Mooncake
Shure: 还在楼下
Shure: Still downstairs
Tasha: 他们还有3个人是吧
Tasha: They still have 3 people, right?
Alice:我们学校前一段还着火了
Alice: Our school had a fire recently.
Tasha: 那好吧
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Jake:为什么呢
Jake: Why?
Jake:用插板吃火锅
Jake: Using a power strip to cook hotpot.
Alice:嗯有人吸烟
Alice: Yeah, someone was smoking.
Alice:哦这好像不让说的
Alice: Oh, I think we're not supposed to talk about this.
Lucia: 无所谓哈哈
Lucia: Doesn't matter, haha.
Alice:没关系啊
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 关系没事他会把这段删掉的哈
Lucia: No worries, they'll just cut this part out, haha.
Jake:跪下不让说
Jake: Kneel down, don't mention it.
Alice:不删也行无所谓
Alice: Even if they don't cut it, it's fine.
Shure: 有人逼逼哈哈哈
Shure: Someone kept blabbing, haha.
Tasha: 第一
Tasha: First
Lucia: 那我给你手动做音效
Lucia: Let me add some sound effects for you.
Shure: 然后他在逼逼的时候他逼逼的哈哈
Shure: And while he was blabbing, he kept on blabbing, haha.
Lucia: 你现在说吧
Lucia: You can speak now.
Alice:哈哈咦
Alice: Haha, okay.
Alice:无所谓这个
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Alice:然后那个救护车开到楼下还在睡觉
Alice: And then the ambulance arrived downstairs, but I was still asleep.
Alice:完全没有听到
Alice: Didn't hear it at all.
Alice:他们在群里一直在吵我们要不要跑
Alice: They were arguing in the group whether we should run or not.
Shure: Monday和你走到Sunday
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice:小的不用跑
Alice: No need to run for the small ones.
Lucia: 小的不用跑大的跑不了
Lucia: Small ones don't need to run, big ones can't run.
Alice:大的跑不了
Alice: Big ones can't run.
Jake:无所谓就是是吧
Jake: Doesn't matter, right?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure.
Jake:打击乐手
Jake: Percussionist.
Alice:这点有餐盘啥的吗
Alice: Do we have trays or something here?
Alice:还是楼下有
Alice: Or are they downstairs?
Tasha: 这好像也有
Tasha: I think we have some here too.
Alice:这个不用洗
Alice: This one doesn't need washing.
Lucia: sorry不是这个
Lucia: Sorry, not this one.
Alice:嗯拿碟装吧
Alice: Hmm, let's use a plate.
Lucia: 嗯碟的话不够
Lucia: Hmm, a plate isn't enough.
Lucia: 咱有8个人
Lucia: We have 8 people.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:你是不是得下楼亲
Alice: Do you need to go downstairs?
Alice:有没有大一点
Alice: Is there a bigger one?
Lucia: 妙妙小工具
Lucia: Handy little tool.
Alice:我想要那个
Alice: I want that one.
Alice:我洗白菜啊
Alice: I'm washing the cabbage.
Lucia: 啊你说你说碗吗
Lucia: Ah, you mean bowls?
Alice:大碗对
Alice: Big bowls, right.
Lucia: 这个碗我前两天洗过
Lucia: I washed this bowl a few days ago.
Lucia: 我涮一下就可以
Lucia: I'll just rinse it.
Lucia: 对但其他的
Lucia: Yes, but the others...
Lucia: 这上面的碗应该还没怎么用过
Lucia: The bowls up there haven't been used much.
Lucia: 我先都拿出来
Lucia: I'll take them out first.
Lucia: 就是先拿8个这个小碗
Lucia: I'll just take 8 small bowls first.
Alice:白菜手撕的好吃
Alice: Hand-torn cabbage tastes better.
Alice:谁懂
Alice: Who knows?
Lucia: 啊太好了
Lucia: Ah, that's great.
Lucia: 我还以为白菜咱昨天用完了呢
Lucia: I thought we used up all the cabbage yesterday.
Alice:我只用了叶没用包
Alice: I only used the leaves, not the core.
Lucia: 我到楼下看看楼下的碗够不够
Lucia: I'll check if there are enough bowls downstairs.
Lucia: 要楼下碗够
Lucia: If there are enough bowls downstairs...
Lucia: 把楼下碗拿上来算了
Lucia: I'll bring them up.
Alice:什么白菜这么脏
Alice: Why is the cabbage so dirty?
Lucia: 要不然话还得再涮一次太麻烦了
Lucia: Otherwise, we'll have to rinse them again, too much trouble.
Shure: 哦我们直接这样
Shure: Oh, we just do it like this.
Shure: 走一下线
Shure: Run a line.
Tasha: 走一下线
Tasha: Run a line.
Katrina: 还有一些小狗
Katrina: There are some puppies.
Shure: 回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Jake:三颗钱还是什么
Jake: Three coins or what?
Katrina: 非常非常丰富
Katrina: Very, very rich.
Jake:三三颗出伪金币吗还是
Jake: Three fake coins or...
Katrina: 哈哈哈都有
Katrina: Hahaha, a bit of everything.
Jake:什么都有
Jake: A bit of everything.
Jake:很多是吧
Jake: Quite a lot, huh?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:要火
Jake: Gonna be popular
Nicous: 这个厕所有人吗
Nicous: Is this restroom occupied?
Shure: 没人吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Katrina: 哇团建的感觉
Katrina: Wow, feels like a team building event.
Jake:一会开吃了再结束吧
Jake: Let's start eating and then wrap it up.
Jake:就是把这个都拆开
Jake: Just open all of this up.
Shure: 好
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Can someone help me out here?
Jake:开吃就
Jake: Let's start eating.
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: What do we need to do?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it in there.
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to do it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两股啊
Katrina: Hey, where can we get two strands?
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, go, go!
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: Then hold this.
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let it stick to anything.
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Alice:这我说这洗不掉
Alice: I told you, this won't wash off.
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this thing?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: This is good enough.
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Yeah, some leaves just have it.
Jake:就没必要了
Jake: No need to bother.
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: They just grow like this, or what?
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: We wash our veggies like this too.
Jake:是没必要了
Jake: No need to bother.
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Touch it.
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data.
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It's supposed to look like this.
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: Looks like it's grown on it.
Jake:数据倒了倒了
Jake: Data is pouring.
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yes, it looks like this.
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Fine, give me a witness.
Alice:证啊
Alice: Certificate.
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I did wash it.
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Okay, don't worry.
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: It just looks like this.
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow.
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put this on top.
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I won't be able to get through later.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I have a pretty good sense of my own weight and worth.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know that, right?
Lucia: 我踩着啥了刚才
Lucia: What did I step on just now?
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Whoa, whoa, whoa
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: Mainly, just don't hit the connection points or anything like that.
Shure: 斯密码塞
Shure: Skid marks
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it off.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, is there no cloth upstairs? Oh, there is.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: This water is clearly less.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes, it is.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: No problem, we'll just refill it with boiling water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Katrina: 先拿抹布擦
Katrina: First, get a cloth to wipe it.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Ah, use Wahaha water.
Lucia: 啊娃哈哈的水啊
Lucia: Ah, Wahaha water, huh?
Tasha: 就是说他的水很健康的感觉
Tasha: Just saying, their water feels really healthy.
Lucia:  实验室用水
Lucia: Lab water.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Shure: 都在用水对
Shure: Everyone's using water, right.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I'm just making stuff up.
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another segment.
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: It's to give you five or six kinds of mineral water.
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: And let you distinguish them.
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Oh, that's doable.
Katrina: 这是你设计的某种游戏吗
Katrina: Is this some sort of game you designed?
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: And then, whoever drinks all the water first is the winner?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can distinguish them.
Shure: 离得太近
Shure: Too close.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: Everything's ready.
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just missing the eastern wind.
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What is the eastern wind?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: The eastern wind is the hotpot base.
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: Where's the hotpot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients.
Katrina: 在楼下
Katrina: Downstairs.
Tasha: 嗯碗有
Tasha: Yeah, there's a bowl.
Lucia: 呃碗有但盘子不够咱就用小碗吧
Lucia: Uh, there's a bowl, but not enough plates. Let's just use small bowls.
Lucia: 哎你已经找到了
Lucia: Hey, you found it already.
Shure: 我找到了啊
Shure: Yeah, I found it.
Tasha: 吃饭也要开棚
Tasha: We need to set up the tent even for eating.
Shure: 有有一个
Shure: Yeah, there's one.
Shure: 要变成纯清汤
Shure: It needs to become a clear soup.
Katrina: 这就一包啊
Katrina: This is just one package.
Shure: 对这就一包
Shure: Yeah, it's just one package.
Tasha: 一包不能拆成两包用吗
Tasha: Can't we split this one package into two?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: It says here it's for 3-5 people.
Katrina: 他这个你撕一下
Katrina: Here, tear this apart.
Shure: 其实也不是不行
Shure: Actually, that's not impossible.
Katrina: 对他应该是一锅的量
Katrina: Right, it's probably meant for one pot.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Katrina: 然后就分成两个半
Katrina: Then just split it in half.
Tasha: 我也撕开
Tasha: I'll tear it open too.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: What level of spiciness can we handle?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Everyone?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can handle a lot of spice.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, all four of us then.
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: In the next one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, there are always crafty people trying to harm me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: I'll make it so spicy you can't handle it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No filming tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's just split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Ouch.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: It's split in half.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Okay, okay, let's just split it in half.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: So this hot pot base has four pieces.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: How about putting two pieces in each?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: I'll put two pieces in mine.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: That's fine.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: From one to another.
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: Just say something casual
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just got back from Chengdu
Shure: 成都哎呀我也去成
Shure: Chengdu, oh I went there too
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One is two
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot for two pieces
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Tasha: One pot for half a bag
Shure: OK那个下到那里面去
Shure: OK, put it in there
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, does half a bag mean
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: that one piece is less in this?
Shure: 不是不是菌汤的那个
Shure: No, no, it's the mushroom soup
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK OK, so we also open this and put it in here
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix
Shure: i missing you my honey
Shure: I miss you, my honey
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you
Shure: tell me
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why is there only this pot with the most water?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what should we do?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: There's only one bag
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: What? One bag isn't enough
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear this bag open
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And pour half out
Shure: 这无需撕开
Shure: No need to tear it open
Shure: 说明他不应该撕开
Shure: It means it shouldn't be torn open
Tasha: 那怎么办
Tasha: Then what to do?
Shure: 随便
Shure: Whatever
Shure: 小公鸡点到谁我就选谁好
Shure: Little rooster points to someone, I'll choose them
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 那这个锅的菌汤该有多么的孤单呀
Tasha: Then how lonely would this pot's mushroom soup be
Tasha: 啊煮一半把它捞出来放这个锅里
Tasha: Ah, cook half and then scoop it out to put in this pot
Shure: 哈哈哈流动料包
Shure: Hahaha, floating seasoning pack
Lucia: 失策早知道两个锅当时应该买两包
Lucia: Miscalculation, should've bought two packs for two pots
Shure: 哦你在切东西
Shure: Oh, you're cutting something
Shure: 厕所有人吗
Shure: Is anyone in the bathroom?
Shure: anyone
Shure: Anyone
Lucia: 应该是没有的意思吧
Lucia: I think it means no one is there
Shure: come in
Shure: Come in
Shure: 我要进来喽
Shure: I'm coming in
Tasha: 妈呀
Tasha: Oh my god
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 好多预热啊哈哈哈
Lucia: So many preheats, hahaha
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿
Shure: Hehehe
Lucia: 3次握手才能确定
Lucia: Three handshakes to confirm
Jake:有啊有啊
Jake: Yes, yes
Lucia: 正在进行握手
Lucia: Currently shaking hands
Shure: i'm missing you my honey don't you
Shure: I'm missing you my honey, don't you
Lucia: 我觉得我们家网经常握手它就握不
Lucia: I feel like our internet often shakes hands and then it doesn't
Shure: 这只扔了
Shure: Throw this one away
Lucia: 顾不上了
Lucia: I can't bother with it now
Shure: 我是一个变忧郁的小丑
Shure: I'm a melancholic clown
Shure: 我们那个河马的那些袋子拿一个
Shure: Grab one of those hippo bags
Shure: 然后当一个垃圾袋吧
Shure: And use it as a trash bag
Shure: 哎你就在那弄
Shure: Hey, you just do it there
Shure: 那你先弄着
Shure: You start first
Lucia: 盒马袋子还有吗
Lucia: Are there any hippo bags left?
Shure: 河马袋子还有吗
Shure: Any hippo bags left?
Shure: 有吧应该
Shure: There should be, right?
Lucia: 哎我把我手机又撂哪
Lucia: Ah, where did I put my phone again?
Lucia: 哎算放那了
Lucia: Ah, just leave it there
Shure: 我们
Shure: Let's
Shure: 放点电影看吧
Shure: Watch some movies
Shure: 大家想看什么类型的电影吗
Shure: What kind of movies does everyone want to watch?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 那我们就看
Shure: Then we'll watch
Shure: 就看
Shure: We'll watch
Shure: 一些下饭的
Shure: Some good meal-time movies
Shure: 哎我的电脑在哪里
Shure: Hey, where's my laptop?
Shure: 我看见了
Shure: I see it
Shure: 我刚刚拿上来
Shure: I just brought it up
Shure: 看见我的电脑吗
Shure: Did you see my laptop?
Shure: 在这里吗
Shure: Is it here?
Shure: 大脑的配合我却从不相信
Shure: I never believe in brain cooperation
Lucia: behold
Lucia: Behold
Shure: 好啊好啊
Shure: Alright, alright
Shure: 他拿了一个大袋子
Shure: He took a big bag
Shure: OK
Shure: 哪边水不够我们再补一点
Shure: If there's not enough water somewhere, we'll add a bit more
Shure: 没有案楼下是不是有案板
Shure: Isn't there a chopping board downstairs?
Lucia: 我觉得这这是不是俩都有点少看起来
Lucia: I feel like both of these look a bit little.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 是不是应该拿个小盘
Shure: Should we get a small plate?
Shure: 这样然后这个是辣锅少是吧
Shure: Like this, and this is the spicy hotpot, right?
Shure: 天啊太气
Shure: Oh my, it's too strong.
Shure: 把那个门关上吧你们
Shure: Can you guys close the door?
Lucia: 哦微
Lucia: Oh, Tasha.
Shure: 不然话会窜进去味的
Shure: Otherwise, the smell will get in.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 微你的门或者我帮你关
Lucia: Tasha, your door, or I can help you close it.
Lucia: 如果你不介意的话
Lucia: If you don't mind.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure: 关好哦大家
Shure: Close it properly, everyone.
Lucia: 我看看我那边啊
Lucia: Let me check mine.
Lucia: 我把我那边也关上
Lucia: I'll close mine too.
Alice:你们介意我把这个魔芋直接拽成
Alice: Do you mind if I just tear this konjac apart?
Shure: 不介意拽吧
Shure: I don't mind, go ahead.
Shure: 我不介意
Shure: I don't mind.
Shure: 有介意的吗
Shure: Anyone mind?
Shure: 他们不敢介意了好拽吧
Shure: They don't dare to mind, go ahead.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 对我们觉得拽着香
Shure: Yes, we think tearing it is more fragrant.
Shure: 就像手撕白菜一样
Shure: Just like hand-torn cabbage.
Lucia: 哦原来魔芋块是长这样的
Lucia: Oh, so konjac chunks look like this.
Shure: i'm missing you my honey
Shure: I'm missing you, my honey.
Lucia: 小心手要不要把那个盘
Lucia: Be careful with your hand, do you want to use that plate?
Alice:再来一个吧谢谢
Alice: Another one, please, thanks.
Alice:我感觉我快没有吃纯熟
Alice: I feel like I'm almost out of konjac.
Tasha: 嗯蘸料呢哦
Tasha: Hmm, where's the dipping sauce?
Tasha: 蘸料是拿来了吗
Tasha: Did we get the dipping sauce?
Alice:蘸料是不是还搁底下呢
Alice: Is the yam still at the bottom?
Lucia: 蘸料刚才好像修硕已经开了
Lucia: I think Shure already opened the dipping sauce earlier.
Alice:是不是在底下呀
Alice: Is it at the bottom?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 醋碟油碟
Tasha: Vinegar dip, oil dip?
Shure: 呃都我只把麻酱给卸了
Shure: Uh, I only took out the sesame paste.
Lucia: 蘸料你是不是打开了一个
Lucia: Did you open one of the dipping sauces?
Shure: 其他的还还没弄
Shure: Haven't done the others yet.
Lucia: 呃有点买了一个小的
Lucia: Oh, got a small one.
Lucia: 我去把它拿上来
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 嗯有点粗点
Tasha: Hmm, a bit rough.
Shure: 什么鬼你来呀来呀你
Shure: What the heck, you come here, come here.
Shure: 大家想看什么呢
Shure: What do you guys want to see?
Shure: 大家想看什么呀
Lucia: 那个麻将我不太清楚放哪了
Lucia: I don't really know where the mahjong is.
Lucia: 但是这两个可以拿上来
Lucia: But we can bring these two up.
Shure: 放在楼下的这个这个地方
Shure: Put it downstairs in this spot.
Lucia: 啊确定吗
Lucia: Ah, are you sure?
Lucia: 我感觉那一块只有一些烘焙原料
Lucia: I feel like that area only has some baking ingredients.
Shure: 不他那一大碗就是麻酱
Shure: No, that big bowl is sesame paste.
Lucia: 啊哈我再看一眼
Lucia: Ah, okay, I'll take another look.
Shure: 对那个碗是我卸好的麻酱
Shure: Yeah, that bowl has the sesame paste I prepared.
Tasha: 啊就带这个带的吗
Tasha: Ah, are we just bringing this?
Tasha: 确实会有点
Tasha: It might be a bit much.
Tasha: 啊人怎么又不见了的感觉
Tasha: Ah, why does it feel like someone disappeared again?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Lucia: 呃有俩人在楼下
Lucia: Uh, there are two people downstairs.
Shure: 我恪守难得好吧
Shure: I'm sticking to it, alright.
Alice:他们回来了吗
Alice: Did they come back?
Lucia: 哎不对啊
Lucia: Wait, no.
Lucia: 回来了应该回来了
Lucia: They should be back.
Lucia: 应该有三个人在楼下呀
Lucia: There should be three people downstairs.
Tasha: 这边这个为什么都冒气
Tasha: Why is this side steaming?
Lucia: 他是不是要把火再开大一些
Lucia: Should we turn up the heat a bit?
Alice:这个水比这个水多一点
Alice: There's more water in this one.
Tasha: 可能这边受热不均匀
Tasha: Maybe this side is heating unevenly.
Tasha: 你看它这个圆圈在这里
Tasha: Look, the circle is here.
Tasha: 它这个圆圈
Tasha: This circle.
Shure: 知道为什么吗因为
Shure: Do you know why? Because...
Tasha: 这样
Tasha: Like this.
Shure: 它的功率大一点
Shure: Its power is a bit higher.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有什么为什么
Shure: Haha, there's no real reason.
Shure: 哦好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Alice:这个水还少呢
Alice: This one has less water.
Shure: 是因为那个
Shure: It's because...
Shure: 我后来不是把开水几乎都加在这边了
Shure: I later added most of the hot water here.
Tasha: 哦这边加的是开水
Tasha: Oh, you added hot water here.
Shure: 所以他开水加的多一点
Shure: So, there's more hot water on this side.
Alice:晚上就熏入味了
Alice: It'll be well-flavored by tonight.
Shure: 有酒能不喝开玩笑
Shure: How can you not drink when there's alcohol, kidding.
Lucia: 已经把朗姆酒打开了
Lucia: I've already opened the rum.
Alice:看来这马上要没了
Alice: Looks like it's almost gone.
Alice:没存储现在已经快3小时了
Alice: No storage and it's been almost 3 hours now.
Shure: 橙汁补满螺丝棋子
Shure: Refill the orange juice, the screwdriver.
Jake:现在还是几
Jake: How many are there now?
Alice:只有20
Alice: Only twenty.
Jake:开个o型开个
Jake: Open an O-shaped one.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Shure: 好喝的小甜水
Shure: A tasty sweet drink.
Shure: 一些酒鬼
Shure: Some drunkards.
Shure: 我可以让火小一点了
Shure: I can lower the heat a bit.
Alice:上面有水吗
Alice: Is there water on top?
Shure: 有啊没有
Shure: Yes, no.
Tasha: 喝可乐就行
Tasha: Just drink Coke.
Tasha: 中午的可乐
Tasha: The Coke from noon.
Tasha: 我觉得火锅应该喝可乐
Tasha: I think hot pot should be paired with Coke.
Shure: 可乐有
Shure: There's Coke.
Shure: 还有啤酒要吗
Shure: And beer, do you want some?
Tasha: 小孩来这桌哈哈
Tasha: Kids, come to this table, haha.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 还有soda water
Shure: There's also soda water.
Shure: 气泡水
Shure: Sparkling water.
Tasha: 椰子水也有
Tasha: There's coconut water too.
Shure: 筷子拿上来了吗
Shure: Did you bring the chopsticks up?
Shure: 上面也有
Shure: There's some upstairs too.
Shure: 稍微涮一涮
Shure: Just swish it a bit.
Alice:你要水不要
Alice: Do you want water?
Alice:我去拿一瓶
Alice: I'll go get a bottle.
Tasha: 要什么
Tasha: What do you want?
Alice:我去拿哦
Alice: I'll go get it.
Tasha: 你可以拿对
Tasha: You can get it, right?
Tasha: 然后对你不喝饮料吗
Tasha: Then you don't drink soda?
Alice:还有啥需要拿上来的
Alice: What else needs to be brought up?
Tasha: 筷子有了
Tasha: We have chopsticks.
Shure: 想起来啥拿啥
Shure: Grab whatever you think of.
Tasha: 是不是少啊
Tasha: Is it not enough?
Shure: 楼下还有筷子
Shure: There are more chopsticks downstairs.
Tasha: 哦还有碗是不是够
Tasha: Oh, and bowls, are there enough?
Shure: 对碗
Shure: Yes, bowls.
Alice:碗够吗
Alice: Are there enough bowls?
Shure: 也
Shure: Yeah.
Tasha: 碗和筷子就行了吧
Tasha: Bowls and chopsticks should be enough, right?
Lucia: 八个碗吗
Lucia: Eight bowls?
Alice:拿筷子呢
Alice: Who's getting the chopsticks?
Shure: 筷子筷子都拿上来吧
Shure: Bring all the chopsticks up.
Lucia: 筷子
Lucia: Chopsticks.
Alice:都拿上来
Alice: Bring them all up.
Lucia: 现在有一二为
Lucia: Now we have one, two...
Shure: 反正是8个人
Shure: Anyway, there are 8 people.
Lucia: 什么是5根筷子
Lucia: Why are there 5 chopsticks?
Tasha: 他拿走了一根
Tasha: He took one.
Tasha: 那就是四双
Tasha: So that's four pairs.
Lucia: 哦你拿走了一根
Lucia: Oh, you took one.
Lucia: 我以为你拿走了一双呢
Lucia: I thought you took a pair.
Tasha: 四双筷子
Tasha: Four pairs of chopsticks.
Tasha: 还差四双
Tasha: We still need four pairs.
Alice:那我先去拿
Alice: I'll go get them.
Shure: 好啤酒放多了
Shure: Okay, too much beer.
Lucia: 我刚想说你倒的好像很多
Lucia: I was just about to say, you poured a lot.
Lucia: 但我以为是你比较能喝
Lucia: But I thought you could handle it.
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Almost.
Lucia: 那个气泡酒能开吗
Lucia: Can we open that sparkling wine?
Shure: 气泡酒开了就得喝了今天
Shure: If we open it, we have to drink it today.
Lucia: 确实哦因为气泡酒加橙汁很好喝
Lucia: True, because sparkling wine with orange juice is delicious.
Lucia: 让我想一想怎么办啧啧啧
Lucia: Let me think about what to do, hmm...
Shure: 怎么路边的野花不是不要采吗
Shure: Aren't you not supposed to pick wildflowers by the roadside?
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 跟跟别人说话
Shure: Just talking to someone else.
Lucia: 突然串台了
Lucia: Suddenly off-topic.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 开饭喽可以吃了
Shure: Dinner's ready, we can eat now.
Alice:叫了嗯但是无动于衷
Alice: I called them, but no response.
Shure: 叫 了吗OK
Shure: Did you call them? Okay.
Tasha: 无动于衷
Tasha: No response.
Shure: 再无动于衷咱就开吃
Shure: If they don't respond, we'll start eating.
Shure: 不等他们
Shure: Don't wait for them.
Shure: 惯着他们
Shure: Spoiling them.
Shure: 一天天的
Shure: Every single day.
Alice:谁没有筷子
Alice: Who doesn't have chopsticks?
Shure: 吃饭都不积极
Shure: Not enthusiastic about eating.
Alice:你要尖筷子还是圆筷子
Alice: Do you want pointed chopsticks or round chopsticks?
Tasha: 啊呃
Tasha: Uh, um...
Alice:只有一双圆筷子
Alice: There's only one pair of round chopsticks.
Tasha: 那就是好
Tasha: That's fine then.
Tasha: 那我就要这双特殊的圆筷子
Tasha: I'll take these special round chopsticks.
Tasha: 不我还是要尖筷子吧
Tasha: No, actually, I'll take the pointed ones.
Alice:那我也要
Alice: Me too.
Alice:我要跟你一样
Alice: I want the same as you.
Alice:算了我用圆的吧
Alice: Never mind, I'll use the round ones.
Alice:因为尖的我可能夹不住
Alice: Because I might not be able to pick up food with the pointed ones.
Lucia: 我也来一点
Lucia: I'll have a bit too.
Shure: 高点
Shure: Higher.
Lucia: 哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Shure: 必须高点
Shure: It has to be higher.
Lucia: 不过我不敢倒你那么多
Lucia: But I can't pour as much as you.
Shure: 哎好了好了可以了其实
Shure: Okay, okay, that's enough.
Shure: 你为什么不用杯子呀
Shure: Why don't you use a cup?
Lucia: 啊因为我懒
Lucia: Ah, because I'm lazy.
Tasha: 现在不给直播了
Tasha: We're not streaming anymore.
Lucia: 就是我把这个喝完了
Lucia: I'll finish this drink first.
Lucia: 我就可以直接拿它来吃饭了哈哈
Lucia: Then I can use it directly for my meal, haha.
Tasha: 我不知道结果
Tasha: I don't know the result.
Shure: 来点嘛雨轩
Shure: Have some, Yuxuan.
Shure: 喝喝
Shure: Drink up.
Katrina: 这是橙汁还是啥东西
Katrina: Is this orange juice or what?
Shure:  ：就是橙汁加朗姆酒
Shure: It's orange juice with rum.
Shure: 好像橙汁不够
Shure: Seems like there's not enough orange juice.
Shure: 你其实对你们都喝不出来什么味
Shure: Actually, you all won't taste much difference.
Lucia: 啊太小看人了吧
Lucia: Ah, you're underestimating us.
Shure: 选个片吧选个片吧
Shure: Let's pick a movie, let's pick a movie.
Shure: 别让我的大脸在这地方待着
Shure: Don't let my big face stay here.
Shure: 太太可怕了
Shure: It's too scary.
Tasha: 是一个独立的国家
Tasha: It's an independent country.
Alice:为什么还是这个龙啊
Alice: Why is it still this dragon?
Tasha: 还是这局
Tasha: Still this game.
Shure: 这是我iPad壁纸
Shure: It's my iPad wallpaper.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:这个能剥吗
Jake: Can you peel this?
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Tasha: 这为什么不能播
Tasha: Why can't this be broadcasted?
Shure: 你还帮忙监督着是吗哈哈
Shure: Are you supervising too? Haha
Tasha: 哦刚刚那段话吗
Tasha: Oh, that last part?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea
Shure: 我也很开心
Shure: I'm happy too
Shure: 因为我有酒喝
Shure: Because I have drinks
Lucia: 没事就算橙汁用完了
Lucia: It's okay, even if the orange juice runs out
Lucia: 咱还有可乐
Lucia: We still have cola
Shure: 这个兑可乐好喝吗
Shure: Is it good with cola?
Lucia: 自由古巴
Lucia: Cuba Libre
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Lucia: 自由古巴的传统兑法吗
Lucia: Traditional Cuba Libre mix?
Lucia: 这不是老母加可乐
Lucia: It's not just rum and cola
Alice:你这
Alice: Wait
Alice:你这屏幕裂了吗还是膜
Alice: Did your screen crack or is it just the protector?
Tasha: 不是膜
Tasha: It's not the protector
Tasha: 什么时候开饭
Tasha: When's dinner?
Jake:可以开了是吧
Jake: Can we start now?
Shure: 可以开始了
Shure: Yeah, we can start
Shure: 其实摆起来吧咱们
Shure: Let's set everything up
Jake:那就摆起来
Jake: Let's set it up
Shure: 然后把这个机器停了吧
Shure: And stop the machine
Shure: 别别弄坏了
Shure: Don't break it
Jake:这个开完就结束录制
Jake: Finish setting up and stop recording
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay
Shure: 到时候没喝完的都得带回去
Shure: Make sure to take any leftover drinks with you
Alice:啊蚂蚁爬上来了
Alice: Ah, ants are climbing up
Jake:这怎么开
Jake: How do you open this?
Jake:这叫刀划吗
Jake: Is this called slicing with a knife?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Jake:有有刀是吗
Jake: Do you have a knife?
Shure: 我还没没确定坐那
Shure: I haven't decided on a seat yet
Shure: 橙汁不够了
Shure: We're out of orange juice
Shure: 可能有点浓
Shure: Might be a bit strong
Shure: 啊可以往里兑养乐多
Shure: Ah, you can mix in some Yakult
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:8个人两个过合适吧
Jake: Two for eight people should be good, right?
Choiszt: 合适特别合适
Choiszt: Perfect, absolutely perfect
Lucia: 这这好紧啊
Lucia: This is so tight
Jake:看你直播
Jake: Watching your live stream
Lucia: 谢谢我看看有啥人能直接撕的
Lucia: Thanks, let me see if there's anything I can tear open directly.
Shure: 我们看点什么
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这是不能撕开啊
Lucia: This can't be torn open.
Shure: 我们看点啥
Shure: What should we watch?
Lucia: 这能撕开耶
Lucia: This can be torn open.
Tasha: 是你们3个人的绿豆糕
Tasha: It's the mung bean cakes for you three.
Tasha: 因为你们3个刚刚不在
Tasha: Because you three weren't here just now.
Choiszt: 哦谢谢这是你做的吗
Choiszt: Oh, thanks. Did you make these?
Tasha: 呃你猜
Tasha: Uh, you guess.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 可以试
Lucia: Can I try?
Jake:这是一个好问题
Jake: That's a good question.
Jake:一款可以问PUA
Jake: It's a question you can ask PUA.
Choiszt: 你要做的肯定好吃
Choiszt: If you made it, it must be delicious.
Tasha: 谢谢
Tasha: Thanks.
Lucia: 虾滑就下的时候再撕吧
Lucia: Tear the shrimp paste when you're about to use it.
Lucia: 呃这这这咋放呀
Lucia: Uh, how do we put this?
Jake:这个也可以撕
Jake: You can also tear this.
Shure: 你有什么想看的
Shure: What do you want to watch?
Shure: 拖火球大会
Shure: The roast battle?
Lucia: 这是那个豆皮啥的应该
Lucia: This should be tofu skin or something.
Shure: 我没有
Shure: I don't have it.
Shure: 腾讯会员
Shure: Tencent membership.
Shure: 我有没有来着
Shure: Do I have it or not?
Shure: 经典搞笑是吧
Shure: Classic comedy, right?
Shure: 夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Goodbye Mr. Loser.
Lucia: 撕了撕了
Lucia: Tore it, tore it.
Lucia: 但是它里面还有个袋子
Lucia: But there's still a bag inside.
Jake:随便看看
Jake: Just watch anything.
Jake:这段不录你爱怎么
Jake: This part is not recorded, do whatever you want.
Lucia: 我知道外面这层撕了
Lucia: I know, I tore the outer layer.
Jake:哎不对
Jake: Hey, wait.
Lucia: 里面那可能是我也不知道它啥意思
Lucia: I don't know what the inner part is for.
Jake:有一圈摄像头在录
Jake: There are cameras recording.
Lucia: 下的时候再撕还是什么吧
Lucia: Tear it when you're about to use it or something.
Shure: 就是要放能播的是吗
Shure: You mean we have to play something that can be broadcast?
Jake:放脸能播的
Jake: Show the face that can be broadcast.
Jake:go Pro还在拍
Jake: The GoPro is still filming.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Lucia: 真真的吧
Lucia: Really, right?
Tasha: 素毛肚吧
Tasha: Vegetarian tripe?
Jake:就是你你在塞博吃火锅
Jake: Yeah, you're having hotpot at Cyber.
Alice:洗一下吗这个
Alice: Should we wash this?
Lucia: 不知
Lucia: No idea.
Choiszt: 洗一下修硕
Choiszt: Shure, wash it.
Shure: 还洗一下吗不干不净
Shure: Should we still wash it? It's not that dirty.
Shure: 吃了没病
Shure: Eating it won't make you sick.
Lucia: 我哎
Lucia: Oh, I...
Lucia: 我以为他这种包装都是直接吃的嘞
Lucia: I thought you could eat this straight out of the package.
Lucia: 不了解
Lucia: I don't know.
Choiszt: 十八点三十二修硕洗毛肚
Choiszt: 18:32, Shure washes the tripe.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 给大家表演一个人类洗毛肚啊
Shure: Let me show you how humans wash tripe.
Jake:可以记下来
Jake: We should note this down.
Lucia: 啊你真的系了
Lucia: Ah, you really washed it.
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know...
Tasha: 把这个包
Tasha: Take this bag...
Lucia: 记一些高光时刻是
Lucia: Record some highlights.
Alice:这个没有吗
Alice: Doesn't this have...
Tasha: 所以我们决定两边一起共用
Tasha: So we decided to share both sides.
Shure: 经典不知道看什么时候
Shure: Classic, don't know when to watch.
Shure: 就看点夏洛特烦恼
Shure: Let's watch some "Goodbye Mr. Loser."
Shure: 哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:迭代一下
Jake: Iterate.
Jake:迭代迭代
Jake: Iterate, iterate.
Jake:多换几个
Jake: Change a few more.
Jake:人气就一直很嗨
Jake: Keeps the energy high.
Jake:开空调吗
Jake: Turn on the air conditioner?
Lucia: 我直接我建议我直接用碗喝水了
Lucia: I think I'll just drink water from a bowl.
Lucia: 所以一会就用这个碗吃
Lucia: So I'll use this bowl to eat later.
Jake:遥控器在哪啊空调
Jake: Where's the remote for the AC?
Lucia: 嗯好问题
Lucia: Hmm, good question.
Alice:是不在那个沙发上那个是吗
Alice: Isn't it on the sofa over there?
Lucia: 黑色电视吗
Lucia: Black TV?
Lucia: 白色
Lucia: White.
Shure: 黑色是电视
Shure: Black is the TV.
Alice:是不是开空调的时候放下去了还是
Alice: Maybe it fell when we turned on the AC?
Shure: 这也不是
Shure: Nope, not here.
Shure: 这是那什么的
Shure: What's this?
Jake:放下去了吗
Jake: Did you put it down?
Shure: 这呢这呢
Shure: Here, here.
Shure: 这呢我放这了
Shure: Here, I put it here.
Jake:这个像确实像
Jake: This looks like it, it really does.
Shure: 就这就是
Shure: Yeah, this is it.
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this?
Shure: 谁调到22度我妈妈在家不揍你
Shure: Who set it to 22 degrees? If my mom was home, she wouldn't let you off.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: Me.
Shure: 26度调好了
Shure: I've set it to 26 degrees now.
Jake:保护地球
Jake: Save the planet.
Jake:人人有责哈哈哈
Jake: It's everyone's responsibility, haha.
Shure: 就是这你说录进去多不好啊
Shure: If this gets recorded, it wouldn't look good.
Shure: 我们还用空调
Shure: We're still using the AC.
Shure: 他真的一点听不到哎
Shure: He really can't hear a thing.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈我们仿佛在看默剧一样
Shure: Haha, it's like we're watching a silent movie.
Jake:嚯这确实经典
Jake: Wow, this is classic.
Jake:来我们干个杯就
Jake: Let's have a drink.
Jake:就come杯
Jake: Just a toast.
Jake:come杯
Jake: A toast.
Jake:有有杯子吗
Jake: Do we have glasses?
Alice:多了
Alice: Plenty.
Jake:好好杯子
Jake: Alright, good, glasses.
Shure: 这一个小底
Shure: Just a small sip.
Shure: 应该喝不出来什么
Shure: You shouldn't taste much.
Jake:我要把我爸把我茅台打上来
Jake: I'll get my dad to bring up the Maotai.
Shure: 干吧
Shure: Cheers.
Shure: 那我坐哪儿
Shure: So where do I sit?
Nicous: 我不知道啊
Nicous: I don't know.
Shure: 那边一个这边一个
Shure: One there, one here.
Choiszt: 我的手湿的
Choiszt: My hands are wet.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 你往你往这边
Shure: Move over here.
Shure: 我们挤一挤
Shure: We'll squeeze in.
Shure: 中间串一个
Shure: Someone in the middle.
Choiszt: 要不从下面在办一个
Choiszt: Or we could set up another one below.
Shure: 没事就坐着呗
Shure: It's okay, just sit down.
Tasha: 他不用看电视
Tasha: He doesn't need to watch TV.
Tasha: 他要观察志愿者
Tasha: He needs to observe the volunteers.
Choiszt: 这什么电视电影啊
Choiszt: What kind of TV movie is this?
Shure: 夏洛特烦恼哈哈
Shure: Charlotte's Troubles, haha.
Tasha: 还演过
Tasha: He also acted in it.
Shure: 你演的是圆滑
Shure: You played a smooth character.
Alice:这个车标
Alice: This car logo...
Lucia: 玛莎拉蒂
Lucia: Maserati.
Alice:他演了这个烧饼
Alice: He played the role of a sesame bun.
Lucia: 哦哈哈
Lucia: Oh, haha.
Jake:干杯吧
Jake: Cheers!
Shure: 干杯
Shure: Cheers.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 你喝这个
Lucia: You're drinking this?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:  那还行
Lucia: That's fine then.
Lucia: 那我拿这玩意也不是那么突兀
Lucia: Then holding this thing isn't so awkward.
Jake:哈哈哈确实
Jake: Haha, indeed.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢你哈哈
Lucia: Haha, thank you, haha.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers.
Shure: eagle life票房大卖哈哈哈
Shure: Eagle Life's box office will soar, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahaha.
Shure: 希望点击百亿啊
Shure: Hope it gets a billion clicks.
Tasha: 这不是开源开源产品吗
Tasha: Isn't this an open-source product?
Jake:卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell.
Jake:对上万star
Jake: Yeah, tens of thousands of stars.
Jake:这个可以
Jake: This is good.
Jake:专业这个专业
Jake: Professional, very professional.
Shure: OK那我们stop recording
Shure: Okay, then let's stop recording.
Alice:老板有筷子吗
Alice: Boss, do you have chopsticks?
Jake:这是吗不是
Jake: Is this it? No, it's not.
Alice:你的筷子呢
Alice: Where are your chopsticks?
Jake:十恶不露
Jake: I never show them.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:对你不用场景
Jake: Yeah, you don't need the scene.
Shure: 有勺子吗
Shure: Do we have a spoon?
Shure: 对咱没有勺子
Shure: Yeah, we don't have a spoon.
Shure: 怎么把这个麻将舀出来呢
Shure: How are we going to scoop out the mahjong pieces?
Jake:咱有有点勺子
Jake: Do we have any spoons?
Lucia: 有那个外卖的勺子
Lucia: We have those takeout spoons.
Jake:有塑料勺子
Jake: We have plastic spoons.
Jake:会画吗哈哈哈哈
Jake: Can you draw? Hahaha
Shure: 不会不会
Shure: No, no, I can't.
Shure: 你这
Shure: Look at you.
Choiszt: 谁买的油碟啊
Choiszt: Who bought the oil dish?